[Music]
one of the most important characters in
anime is none other than the rival
usually taking the form of a humongous
obstacle that the hero must overcome the
rival pushes him beyond his limits
you'll see these characters as opposites
of the hero in terms of personality
motivation or philosophy with the
abundance of awesome rivalries in anime
throughout the years I'm here to present
some interesting rivalries that the
mediums brought to us on this list we go
through 10 of the best rivalries in
anime aster and you know of black clover
kick things off childhood friends and
foster brothers ask that and you know
share an interesting relationship
growing up together both characters are
competing for the title of Magic Emperor
with a sense of mutual respect however
it didn't all start out this way asters
the one who inspired you know to be the
magic Emperor thanks to his actions of
course being the person that he was at
the start of the series asked his lack
of magic and hyperactive tendencies
turned his foster brother cold towards
him but we always knew deep down he
always believed in respected aster
[Music]
next up at number nine is the rivalry
between Zorro and sanjeev it's an
understatement to say the straw hats
master swordsman is chef had a rough
start always fighting one another you
could say they're always at each other's
throats
even over the pettiest matters the
rivalry runs deep and as roots with the
two pirates philosophies with the
earliest of this being shown in armies
are long argh
now the two developed a mutual respect
for each other's fighting skills and
their combination in battle is
unstoppable they also have a deep sense
of trust towards each other and their
rivalries allowed them to know each
other quite well beyond the insults and
nicknames are two valuable members of
the crew whose friendships been forged
by fire
[Music]
the rivalry between fo and send owes at
number eight on the list in a shounen
anime you'd expect the hot-blooded
sendou to be the protagonist but instead
he's one of the key rivals with his
fiery reckless attitude he's an ideal
foil for a PO who handed him his first
loss on screen in spite of the
contrasting personalities fo and sendou
have more similarities than what can be
seen on the surface both have a similar
fighting style family backgrounds and
goals in boxing but outside the rink the
two are friends maybe this is the reason
why they're two bouts of hike filled
matches it seems that the two are built
to be each other's worthy opponents
[Music]
coming in at number seven is midoriya
and bar Cougars rivalry in most shown
end shows we see the wide-eyed and
idealistic main character paired with
the more realistic cynical equal that's
why I find it quite nice actually that
my hero academia just changed things up
a little bit instead of pairing our
protagonists with the obvious choice
Todoroki he gets paired with his
childhood friend and eventual bully Baku
go throughout the season Midori and Baku
goes friction filled relationship
continues and has made more intense with
Daegu getting the better of mr.
explosions a couple of times
despite the fighting and antagonism
between them they managed to work
together on rare occasion and it's not
only once Baku goes let his true
feelings out the relationship between
the rivals runs deep and is complicated
and could buy a notable case of jealousy
on the part of Baku though she soars
legendary conflict with Isaiah put that
rivalry in the sixth spot the battles
between Shizuo and Isaiah are well known
throughout a kabocha row as they have
one of the most antagonistic
relationships in all of Durarara how can
they not fight after all their major
opposites to each other in fact it's
hate at first sight for the two with
suzuha throwing the first punch in his
ire responding in kind while she's war
is impulsive and direct with his actions
Isaiah is cerebral calm and manipulative
and noticeable characteristic of a troll
who's Beyond Good and Evil hatred
between the two stems from a simple
exchange
Shizuo immediately sees Isaiah for what
he is and Isaiah can't accept that his
dumb brute of a man can see through his
plots and scheming before we continue
I'd like to give a shout out to this
video sponsor brickbreaker quest
brickbreaker quests a new game for the
iOS and Android platform by mobile
Rick's where you shoot balls at breaks
in order to knock them out it's a great
free-to-play game to relax your mind
with tons of different stages and
various types of balls it's really easy
to get into with its simple game system
designed for one handheld game play and
guess what you can even play this game
or flight so if you don't know what to
do while your Wi-Fi is down well just
play this game there's an achievement
and leaderboard system supported by the
game so if you think you can beat my
score go to the link in the description
and download the
[Music]
and number five we have the rivalry
between Alucard and Anderson it's just
right that the world's strongest vampire
has the Vatican's ultimate vampire
hunter for a rival don't you agree with
that in addition to being peers in
strength with multiple similarities the
two are fitting polar opposites in
nature it seemed destined to battle and
it shows in their actions as the series
progresses there's respect between the
two with Alucard acknowledging
Anderson's will and desire to destroy a
mighty vampire like him and this is the
only opponent worthy of respect from a
low card unfortunately this deeply
rooted respect comes to an end once
Anderson gave up his humanity in his bid
to destroy the vampire rounding out our
pre top three list is the pair of Naruto
and Sasuke has anyone not heard of this
rivalry Naruto and Sasuke are perfect
foils to each other while Naruto is loud
dreamy and idealistic Sasuke is quiet
analytical and cynical on a serious
level Sasuke is also filled with hatred
a stark contrast to his friendly and
understanding rival what's even more
notable is that Sasuke's never got power
creep like most shown in rivals he
remained an integral part of the story
right up until the end I never really
felt throughout the story that Sasuke
truly been usurped by his rival in the
Power Rankings he's frequently ahead of
the main protagonist in terms of power
level making this rivalry one with an
intrigue field end point as the series
went on it's only fitting that they have
their decisive showdown as the last
battle of the series Sasuke is the
embodiment of all the philosophies and
struggles that Naruto had to go through
in his hero's journey and it's fitting
that he ends his adventure with a good
old one-on-one with his rival
starting off our top three is the
rivalry featuring the duo of Kenshin and
Saito
Kenshin & Saito a two swordsmen who've
had their share of history fighting for
opposite sides in the Bakumatsu era
there's no love lost between the two
when they encountered each other after
the war unlike Sinofsky who's a rival
turned friend Saito was never converted
by Kenshin to his side and in all of his
appearances he was shown to be in
tip-top shape as if he's ready to have
another epic duel with Kenshin in spite
of the antagonism between the pair
they've shown themselves to be more than
capable allies they've teamed up on
numerous occasions most notably the
battle against shishio the two may be
rivals but they also show a deep respect
for each other's prowess with Kenshin
considering the former member of the
Shinsengumi a trustworthy companion
[Music]
our runner-up is the rivalry between
Goku and Vegeta you can't have a rivalry
list without judo Goku and Vegeta now
can we this rivalry is about as classic
anime rivalry as you can get and I think
this rivalry needs much explaining at
all actually while around half of Dragon
Balls opponents can be considered a
rival to Goku none of their rivalries
have as much legacy as Vegeta's starting
out as a villain of Vegeta's frequent
battles with his peer lead him to
breaking out as a character and becoming
a series main state to provide a
parallel to our main hero it wouldn't
surprise me if Vegeta is the first thing
in anime fans Minds when it comes to
naming a rival character he's not just a
rival he's the rifle in anime the
competitive nature of the relationship
between them has codified the archetype
of the Shonen anime rival for years to
come when it's all said and done
why else could top this rivalry well
actually there is one in my opinion and
is coming up next
[Music]
at last at number one we have the
glorious rivalry between light and L did
you see this one coming aid if you've
been watching anime during the
late-2000s you probably predicted this
rivalry showing up somewhere on this
list the core attraction of Death Note
is night & L's rivalry notably the two
of them never actually fight directly
instead their battles take the form of
mental jewels and attempts at
outmaneuvering each other you see L
knows that light is Kira but he has no
proof of that to expose it on the other
hand light doesn't know Al's real name
so he can't just killed the detective in
order to get him off his trail the game
of cat-and-mouse between the two
geniuses is what Death Note prides
itself on according to a lot of people
the series seemed to lose its shine when
the baton of the brains came to an end
ELLs replacements never had that
charisma that he possessed and while
they were successful in defeating light
it just felt underwhelming instead of
cathartic
Saguna
and with that we conclude the list I'm
sure that there are a lot more that I
couldn't include you to time constraints
I'm really interested hearing your
opinions on some of the key rivalries in
anime who else do you think deserves a
spot on this list comment below and let
me know now if you enjoyed the video
like share and subscribe also if you'd
like to support the channel please
consider joining the channel membership
I'd really appreciate it don't forget to
check out our sponsors game brickbreaker
quest links in the description I'll see
you next time on beanie tube
[Applause]